alors ok un Scodelario et Thomas
Brodie-sangster merci beaucoup d'
être avec nous aujourd'hui à Paris c'était bien
pour tout le monde à la fin du tournage de
la main Maze Runner vous serez sous
celui-là je veux dire la production a décidé de
faire celui-là avant  l'énorme succès du
premier, nous ne le savions pas, je veux
dire, le plan était toujours de faire les trois
films, un, deux ou trois. Je
pense que nous l'avons découvert juste avant la sortie du premier
film, car ils ont vu à
quel point le film était excité.  les fans étaient et à quel point
il devenait populaire et ils voulaient
tourner très rapidement alors nous avons
commencé à tourner alors que le film était encore
dans les cinémas en Amérique donc c'était très
rapide qu'est-
ce que ça change, je veux dire pour vous,
c'était un énorme succès de  le premier en
termes de beaucoup de choses, je suppose que je pense que
nous sommes tous plutôt reconnaissants pour l'
opportunité que cela nous a donnée et bien vous
savez, nous avons tous travaillé très dur pendant
longtemps pour en
arriver là.  beaucoup de films indépendants, nous sommes tous
venus de différentes manières, mais c'est assez
similaire, nous
travaillons tous depuis longtemps, donc pouvoir faire un
film comme celui-ci, je pense que cela aide pour les
projets que nous voulons faire  vous savez, nous
savons que peut-être que maintenant nous pouvons financer
quelque chose qui autrement ne serait pas
financé, nous avons plus de choix peut-être ouais
un peu plus de choix mais je pense que nous sommes tous
vraiment très fiers d'eux, c'est
bizarre de penser à eux comme ayant réussi
parce que nous tournons très vite, nous tournons
avec un budget assez petit par rapport à
d'autres films comme le nôtre et en fait, nous nous aimons
vraiment donc nous n'avons pas
l'impression de faire un film hollywoodien
trois questions
d'où viens-tu où vas-tu
comment puis-je le laisser tomber ne répondez pas à tous ça
se termine ici pour les montagnes je cherche
le bras droit tu cherches des fantômes
tu veux dire change tes petites choses pour
toi pas que je sache
oui il y avait une fille qui pleurait je fais  les filles qui
pleurent s'il te plaît, laisse-toi avoir la
fille frontale, elle pleure ne le dit pas à Thomas, j'aime
Haley donc elle t'aime bien, elle
ne va pas bien Hé, merci si elle pleure, je
ne sais pas pourquoi elle t'aime autant,
ça la fait pleurer, je  je sais, je ne comprends pas très bien
ouais, je veux dire, ça a été un
changement majeur, je veux dire, ouais, je veux dire, du point de vue de
la carrière, c'est comme si je disais que c'est juste une
expérience amusante, c'est
une autre, je suppose que c'est juste un autre travail
mais c'est bien plus que moi  c'est euh, c'est une
expérience vraiment amusante, j'aime
faire des films, j'aime travailler avec
tout le monde, il y a une partie de ces films et
j'attends avec impatience le prochain, c'était le
même processus qu'un acteur pour faire celui-ci, l'un
des premiers, j'ai dit cela parce que le
premier  est-ce que le champ dans le labyrinthe
est un vrai voyage, je veux dire et c'est
très très chaotique au sommet, donc
en tant qu'acteur, c'était le processus oui M, ce
sont des domaines très différents des
deux films, les premiers très confinés
sont très piégés, c'est  très claustrophobe,
c'est euh, tout tourne autour des peurs d'
être piégé et emprisonné et la
seconde concerne les peurs d'
être si exposé que si ouvert
visuellement et elles sont très différentes mais
vous ressentez ce début parce que vous êtes dans un
décor  c'est très très différent, nous sommes
dans un endroit complètement différent, nous avons
tourné le premier dans un endroit très humide, en fait,
je pense qu'il est en dessous du niveau de la mer,
oui, en Louisiane et le second
était à 5 000 pieds au-dessus du niveau de la mer à
Albuquerque et dans les montagnes où nous  J'ai
jusqu'à 8 000 pieds, c'est très sec, très
sec et dans les deux films, vous avez vraiment l'impression que je l'ai fait. Je
pense que j'ai déjà senti que
l'Occident a toujours été très doué pour rendre
les lieux très semblables à un personnage,
c'est vrai, c'est une vraie partie  de la
rotation des films le nourrissent en tant qu'acteur et
je pense que vous le voyez également à l'écran,
vous pensez qu'il y aurait énormément d'
effets spéciaux, mais je
pense qu'avant, ils s'intégraient simplement dans les
détails et peignaient vraiment.  plus que
créer le monde entier, le monde était
là pour nous physiquement c'était
complètement différent je pense que pour nous
surtout Dylan et Ki Hong dans le
premier ils ont beaucoup couru, ils étaient très
physiques mais nous ne l'avons pas fait et nous
l'avons transformé  dans cette seule chose, il serait
la même chose et a eu un terrible choc
au cours de la première semaine de mon Dieu, nous
devons en fait être en forme et faire face à
l'altitude et à toutes les choses dont
Thomas parlait et je pense
aussi que nous  Je savais que celui-ci, nous
devions l'explorer un peu plus en profondeur,
en particulier pour mon personnage. La raison pour laquelle je me
suis inscrit à ces films était parce que je
connaissais son parcours et son arc dans le
second, c'est pourquoi je voulais
être cette femme et  donc pour moi, c'était une
expérience totalement différente en tant qu'acteur.
J'ai dû être très insulaire, très solitaire, très
observateur, très calme et ce qui est
difficile à faire quand on est vraiment de bons
amis avec huit autres grandes personnalités très bruyantes
et mais c'était totalement  un
sentiment différent pour moi et je pense
que c'est ce qui est génial dans ces films
et le voyage et le troisième, je
pense encore une fois, sera complètement différent
et c'est tellement excitant, c'est tellement cool,
toujours excitant, comme travailler
avec le reste du casting, mieux cela
pourrait être un  camp d'été, c'est peut-être
très dangereux si c'est un camp d'été, vous
voyez ce que je veux dire parce que c'est un travail, alors
n'est-ce pas seulement ouais, nous avions en quelque sorte
un équilibre parfait entre le fait que nous nous
respectons tous et respectons le
métier dans lequel nous étions  aussi et respectons
toutes les personnes impliquées dans la réalisation d'un film et
je pense que nous sommes tous très conscients de la
chance que nous avons d'occuper ce poste et
nous en avons donc tiré le meilleur parti lorsque nous sommes sur le
plateau et lorsque nous sommes sur le plateau.  ensemble, nous sommes jolis, c'est
joli vraiment, je pense que j'aime
penser à nous comme étant plutôt
professionnels et quand nous avons l'
occasion de nous détendre, c'est comme ça que nous
devenons un peu plus détendus quand il s'agit
de calme ouais ouais nous savons comment avoir  c'est un
bon moment mais je pense que ce qui est cool c'est
que quand il s'agit de moments critiques, nous
pouvons aussi y arriver et nous pouvons être
professionnels et nous respecter les uns les autres,
nous voulons faire un bon film que
nous avons tous fait dès le premier  Je
pense que cela fait
ressortir un tel enthousiasme en vous et
il est tellement inspirant dans le sens où vous vous
asseyez avec lui pendant cinq minutes et
tout à coup vous vous dites que nous allons faire
quelque chose d'incroyable, c'est ce qui nous a
rapprochés au début, je pense que le
le fait que nous étions tous comme deux minutes
en fait - ouais ouais, c'était aussi très
difficile pour West, je veux dire, le premier
peut-être en tant que réalisateur pour lui, il n'y avait peut-être que
deux lieux et celui-ci, vous avez
beaucoup d'effets spéciaux GI et
quelque chose comme  que
même pour West, vous pensez que c'était un
film différent bien sûr, mais c'était peut-être plus
difficile en tant que médecin, très bien, je me
souviens qu'il m'a dit qu'il avait
du mal avec le fait que nous étions
constamment en groupe dans celui-ci, donc vous si
vous  pensez-y simplement à la pure logistique consistant à
afficher les visages de huit personnes à l'écran
dans un ensemble, à configurer la caméra, à configurer
l'éclairage, c'est beaucoup plus grand,
c'est beaucoup plus grandiose, vous n'avez pas le
luxe d'avoir seulement deux personnes et de savoir
comment vous allez les photographier.  vous
devez soudainement être très créatif avec
le temps et l'argent et comment vous dépensez
cela et comment tirer le meilleur parti d'avoir
tout le monde ensemble, donc je pense qu'il y
avait quelques défis pour lui là-
dedans, mais le gars prospère grâce à ce genre
de chose  comme si je ne l'avais jamais vu se mettre en
colère une fois, je ne l'ai jamais vu être
submergé par la situation, il est
incroyable et pour avoir dit que vous savez, c'est
le deuxième film qu'il fait et et
il a encore fait un travail incroyable, ce qui
a été le plus  chose difficile à faire pour vous
sur celui-ci, je veux dire physiquement ou comme
jouer avec CGI, je veux dire l'écran bleu
ou ou vous connaissez un écran vert ou
quelque chose comme ça,
il n'y avait pas énormément d'
écran bleu ou de lecture à faire avec Michael
Sainte avant la plupart des trucs étaient
là, nous avions de vrais manivelles et nous
avions un vrai paysage brûlé et ouais,
viens oh ouais ouais ouais ouais je suis toujours
pour ça, je préférais de loin être dans
un environnement laid et plus dur que d'être
coincé dans un  studio climatisé,
je ne suis pas sûr que ça ne marche pas quelque part,
tu préfères jouer pour réagir, je
veux dire avec le vrai personnage et nous,
ouais, mais c'était un
défi physique, c'est la chose la plus
difficile physiquement que j'ai jamais eue.  jamais fait, je pense que
oui, c'était oui, nous étions là, il y avait beaucoup
de course à l'altitude, ils ont joué
un rôle assez important simplement parce que l'
oxygène à cette altitude est
nettement plus faible et
vous êtes essoufflé très rapidement, c'est
très difficile  le récupérer en remontant
une autre dune de sable est incroyablement
difficile simplement parce que c'est une
chose vraiment difficile à faire
en courant sur Sanders, cela ne regarde pas
seulement dans l'index une crique drôle, ils
auraient dû laisser la sortie dans ceux-ci
montrent aux gens à quel point c'est dur  c'était et ça fait
tellement mal que tu ne bouges pas
tu restes juste au même endroit en descendant
c'est horrible ouais et tu restes la tête en bas
aussi c'est dur
ce n'était pas très sympa ok bien tu
penses que tu as grandi à travers les deux
films un Labyrinthe  Coureur en tant que personne, je veux dire en tant qu'être
humain, j'ai dit cela parce que cela
pourrait être une sorte de métaphore sur notre
société et qu'il était difficile pour moi d'être un
jeune adulte en ce moment dans le monde, donc en tant
qu'être humain, vous grandissez vous-même
pendant les deux  tournage ouais pour le dire, je
pense que nous l'avons tous fait, je veux dire, c'est quand nous avons
tourné le premier dans Je savais qu'elle était la
première toi il y a trois ans il y a deux trois
ans il y a trois ans ouais seulement
trois ans, c'est une période de
temps importante pour grandir  de
toute façon, je pense que nous l'avons tous
eu, nous avons grandi autour de ces films et les
uns autour des autres aussi, donc nous avons en quelque
sorte grandi ensemble, ce qui a été sympa
et oui, je veux dire et il y a
des métaphores dans notre film sur ce que c'est que de
grandir pour les jeunes et oui, je
suppose que nous jouons des gens qui sont
légèrement plus jeunes que nous ne le sommes maintenant, mais maintenant
nous avons tous été là, nous avons tous été dans
cette situation et à cet âge, euh  c'est
intéressant euh je t'ai vu grandir je
sais que c'est comme une différence entre toi moi ouais
ta confiance est meilleure prédis que ta
confiance en ton confesseur a grandi et
la tienne moi j'ai beaucoup grandi je
ne sais pas comment c'est arrivé et  J'ai
fait beaucoup de choses en grandissant mais oui, ça a été
agréable de voir tous les garçons devenir des héros.
Je pense que les garçons mettent un peu
plus de temps que les femmes à grandir et ils sont
tous à l'âge où ils se disent soudainement
peut-être.  Je suis un homme maintenant
c'est vraiment mignon méchante [ __ ] ça change
tu es plus intelligente tu es plus claire
très plus intelligente je veux dire la femme que
j'aimerais apprendre j'ai toujours aimé apprendre
je l'ai toujours été et je pense  c'est
important d'apprendre mais mon
expérience personnelle est que les femmes
grandissent légèrement en avance sur les hommes,
comment faire avec ça ouais je pense que ça fait
longtemps que tu commences à te lancer dans le cinéma
Thomas donc je veux dire, est-ce
difficile de survivre  sur le
secteur du cinéma, car il est dit que parce que
beaucoup de jeunes acteurs disparaissent et
oui, vous les volez là et merci
beaucoup parce que vous êtes vraiment
prêts, donc c'est toujours une belle flèche de
vous voir, mais ce qui est difficile, je veux dire,
survivre  cette entreprise et vous avez un
bon ami, votre famille est super pour vous,
je pense que c'est ce dont vous avez
vraiment besoin avant tout, à part
avoir tout ce que vous connaissez, d'excellents agents,
vous avez besoin de cette bonne connexion avec
la réalité parce que c'est un travail assez étrange
et si vous y pensez comme à un travail, ce qui
est étrange, c'est aussi une
passion et quelque chose que j'adore
et que j'aime et j'aime j'aime les gens j'aime les
personnages que j'aime
depuis que je suis enfant  J'ai
toujours mis des voix et étudié les gens sur
le tube à la maison et je vois que j'ai
toujours été étonné de voir à quel point chaque personne
dans le monde est complètement différente
des autres malgré le fait
que vous savez, de nos jours, tout le monde essaie si
fort d'être  comme quelqu'un que vous connaissez, vous savez, qui
fait de grands efforts pour changer son
corps pour s'assurer qu'il ressemble à son
idole, vous savez, j'aime vraiment le fait
qu'ils soient tous si différents et donc pour moi,
la principale chose qui me
motive est  c'est une bonne éducation, ce sont de
bons amis proches, une bonne famille, mais aussi juste
une sorte de volonté de toujours jouer
une personne différente, un personnage différent
et de voir comment cela se rapporte à moi et à
une connexion à chaque fois, n'est-ce pas, ouais, ouais,
ouais, je pense que tu dois sortir  d'un
intérêt et aussi je ne pense pas que
cela serait ancré dans la réalité,
je ne pense pas que ce serait crédible pour un
public donc et aussi c'est intéressant
pour moi juste pour que vous sachiez même si c'est un
personnage qui  ne pas être d'accord ou ne pas
sympathiser avec le fait de se forcer, un
peu comme ce que je disais,
être capable de sympathiser à un certain niveau
est juste une
dynamique mentale intéressante pour vous-même personnellement,
de toute façon, parfois, c'est plus excitant d'
être  un méchant ou un méchant ouais c'est pourquoi
nous voulons nous venger oh ouais tu serais génial
j'adorerais toujours jouer au bagger, ils
ne me coûtent tout simplement pas je veux dire, il y a un
business de film de survie difficile et
il faut avoir un bon  ami ou
supposez que oui, je pense que je veux dire, ça a l'air si
ringard mais c'est vrai que c'est ça,
il s'agit d'avoir de bonnes personnes normales
autour de vous et et j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
non plus que mes amis que j'ai
aujourd'hui ne sont mes amis que j'avais dans  à l'école,
ils ne sont pas acteurs, ils ne veulent
rien savoir de l'industrie du cinéma,
ils s'en fichent, ouais, c'est un indice
parfois à la clé, je veux dire, ouais, ils
s'en fichent, quand je rentre à la maison, tu sais, nous
parlons de choses normales.  et vous savez,
ils me rappellent qu'ils doivent payer un
loyer et qu'ils ont des enfants à
charge et qu'ils ne séjournent pas dans de beaux
hôtels à travers le monde et j'aime que
ce n'est pas la vie les gars non, c'est super pour
une journée alors j'y retourne  à Islington, vous
le faites pendant plus d'une journée, c'est nul, un
homme doit vous affecter mais je pense que c'est
la clé, ma mère est une grande inspiration
pour moi en tant que femme et en tant qu'amie et mon
chien aime les petites choses stupides comme ça
comme  rentrer à la maison et enfiler votre
pantalon préféré que vous ne pourriez
jamais porter en public parce que les gens
diraient qu'il est bon marché ou laid ou
autre et regarder la télévision ou voir
vos amis tels qu'ils sont, c'est ce qui
me sauve chaque jour et c'est  la chose avec laquelle j'ai
le plus de mal avec le travail, c'est
d'être loin de chez moi et le nom de
ton chien est Arnie parce que tu es le grand
fan de Je ne ferai pas confiance à une fille ouais
c'est vrai ouais tu l'as rencontré non je sais que je le
ferais  je m'évanouirais, je pleurerais et je m'évanouirais et non
je rougis en y pensant parfois si
je te le promettais peut-être
ouais d'accord j'ai rencontré Arnold je vois ça quand il
entre maintenant tu es surprise surprise
souviens-toi que je sais bien que c'est ta vie
ouais surprise  ouais ouais donc tu es prêt
pour le prochain coureur de mesure, je veux dire le
numéro un numéro deux et la poignée de
celui-ci, je ne veux pas m'envoyer
quoi que ce soit qui soit un oups
donc tu es prêt pour le chapitre trois
ouais je pense que nous sommes tous excités je  suis
surtout, je pense que ça va être vraiment
intéressant pour moi d'aller dans
un nouvel endroit, nous allons
être dans un environnement totalement différent,
nous allons être de nouveau ensemble, ce qui est
toujours excitant pour nous, nous commençons en
février donc je pense que nous  Nous sommes tous du genre, nous
n'avons pas lu de script ou quelque chose comme
ça ouais mais nous avons confiance, où faisons-nous confiance
aux scénaristes, ça va aller
non, je pense que nous l'attendons tous avec impatience
parce que vous savez que cela signifie quelque chose
si vous interviewez un membre.  du casting
ou de l'équipe, vous savez, cela signifie beaucoup
pour toutes les personnes impliquées dans ce film, c'est
quelque chose que je pense que tout le monde tient
à cœur. Je pense que nous avons
juste hâte de finir en beauté et de le
conclure en beauté et
de faire  numéro quatre, ce sera ça oui
le dernier juste trois juste un trois et
un prequel qui sait qui sait comment
attendrions-nous ce low cost non tu
vas être comme 30 10 50 euros
kyon Thomas merci beaucoup c'était un
super  au plaisir de vous revoir aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup Monsieur merci beaucoup
Musée